by now you've no doubt seen what's
happened in Chicago which is horrible I
wasn't planning on doing a video today
we're actually prepping for the daily
show that launches here on YouTube
January 9th on Monday Gary Sinise is
going to be our first guest so thanks to
him but felt the need to talk about this
the hate crime to use the left's term
that was committed in Chicago
here's a brief clip or overlay and we
can't use too much of that because
YouTube or Twitter will take it down we
wouldn't want any fake news there mind
you this is one of those things that's
really important so stay with me here
here was the ensuing media reaction to
what really should have been a unifying
moment this is something where everybody
should be on board or at least similarly
on board when it comes to their
reactions but this is how the media
reacted we cannot callously go about
classifying things as a hate crime you
know although they are adults they're 13
kids make stupid decision call them kids
they're legally adults but they're young
adults and they make stupid decisions I
think some of us just I don't think it's
evil III don't think it's evil I think
these are young people and I think they
have bad home training for those who
haven't watched the real video a couple
of black people kidnapped a
special-needs white guy beat him so
badly he was basically scalped you could
see his scalp yelled white people white
people insinuated actually outright said
that it was because he voted Donald
Trump I have no idea if this guy did
vote Donald Trump and made the
special-needs man drink toilet water
again for white people for white people
but the jury is still out
we don't really know this is proof
positive 100% that the media doesn't
care about actual racism at all when you
see it right in your face blatantly well
we don't know they're more concerned
with non racism they only care about
black people when it suits their
political agenda they only care about
using them as a political tool they're
less offended by this then they will be
with a front page story running on
somebody who accidentally used the term
colored people instead of people of
color and you have the United States
right now this is the Trump reaction
they're really scared
because they see well you know what here
I said this
before I said this about black lives
matter I said the result I hate to be
that guy saying I but I talked about the
result that would occur if you continued
to vilify cops and white people this way
when they put out their this idea that
cops in record numbers are simply
killing black people because of a level
of melanin in their skin for benign
activities and no reason at all what
does that do well it makes it okay to
vilify cops it makes it okay to
dehumanize cops and it makes it okay to
treat them sub humanely my point is that
if you are not honest if you are simply
using a false narrative to try and
generate cliques you then allow somebody
to aim their latest outrage cannon and
whoever subject you deemed to be
suitable so I don't know kidnapping a
special needs guy beating them down to a
scalp making him drink toilet water
while you yell for white people white
people is that sub humane I would say so
but that's me mr. old-fashioned here we
are at a point where people are scared
Dallas PD shooting people are terrified
and of course this might be happen with
black lives matter no no no no we see
these kinds of hate crimes we've seen
several of these in Chicago people are
scared that's why they're voting for a
Donald Trump they're afraid of the
political correctness they're afraid of
black lives matter who essentially as
you see III know by the way the hashtag
BL I'm kidnapping these people aren't
officially associated with black lives
matter that was meant to be ironic to
point out the sentiment expressed by
black lives matter and the congruence
with this kind of crime but these are
anecdotal examples so Dallas PD people
feel that vibe but it's anecdotal so you
can look to statistics record rise and
attacks on police officers despite the
media telling you that that's not
occurring record crime occurring in
Chicago and it's and by the way we're
talking about the sharp spike in grass
that can be directly attributed but of
course you have a bunch of media doing
damage control from mainstream networks
to non black white guy Shawn King who's
hired as a Young Turks token black guy
to of course our favorite race baiter in
chief to wreak nasheed who said
notice how the miss named hashtag BLM
kidnapping suspects don't have any
unions or organizations funding
protecting them from prosecution
come again stupid what okay you believe
that if white people kidnapped a black
person
said black people black people voted
Hillary Clinton [ __ ] you
black people beat the black person down
to within an inch of their scalp and
made the mentally [ __ ] black person
drink toilet water that they would have
organizations lining up to fund the
defense of a white guy I think the guy
who was kidnapped is more qualified to
commentate than you Tariq nasheed by the
way if you're more offended at the fact
that I used a black sounding voice or
use the word mentally [ __ ] instead
of special needs you are part of the
problem you are exactly part of the
problem nothing that I said there was
hateful nothing that I said there was
wrong or designed to insult
special-needs people I volunteer my wife
does we work with them the left has you
so concerned people are it's not about
racism it's not about caring
it's about virtue signaling wah-wah he
said mentally [ __ ] let me leave a
youtube comments so I think I'm making
an impact on the world chipped it two
changes up he did a black voice let's
act like that's racist right now and
let's pretend that we're outraged
because we can show everyone how
tolerant we are how about you be more
outraged instead of me using the word
mentally [ __ ] that was by design was
a litmus test at the person who was
beaten within an inch of their life
scalp while people yelled out white
people [ __ ] white people Donald Trump
why is that not more outrageous to you
and here's something to that is that is
a silver lining I I hate to I hope they
find justice for these people I know
you're never supposed to hit a woman so
I would not hit the woman involved but I
put damn I just I hope they put her in
an orange is the new black cell with
someone who has been deprived of love
and identifies as a woman and I hope the
reverse is true for the guy except I
hope he's always been a guy I don't want
a woman who identifies as a guy because
he might be strong I I want them to be
accosted in prison I hope I've made that
crystal clear for you here's the silver
lining the media right here here was a
moment kind of like 9/11 every one
unified everyone came together said
alright let's let's put aside her
squabbles we really need to we really
need to come together as Americans
here's a moment for everyone watching
this video everyone watching media by
the way at a time when mistrust of media
is an all-time high I'm not talking fake
news on Facebook that Mark Zuckerberg
has to walk in and curate I'm talking
ABC NBC CBS CNN MSNBC would you look at
the statistics people do not trust
mainstream media here was a moment where
pee
kidnapped a special needs but the only
thing that could rally people in a more
unifying way would be puppies because
PETA even they don't get out of their
bed for a special needs person but if
puppy is involved they're gonna be
protesting topless but still we're
getting close this is a moment where
everyone in the united states watches
this sees a white person kidnapped by
two black people a special needs person
beaten forced to drink toilet water
while they yell [ __ ] white people white
people and oh my gosh the reaction is
the same the media had a glowing
opportunity here to at least partially
redeem themselves by saying all right
you know what this this is a gimme okay
that this isn't a black I played
knockout game and knock out an old white
person is it a hate crime is it gang
affiliation this one I mean they're
they're yelling out that it's because
they hate white people and Donald Trump
this is a gimme you know what let's
let's go with this let's call it what it
is if they'd all the media had to do
here to redeem themselves was to report
the facts and tell the truth and instead
as you see they buried themselves and
nailed their own coffin and I don't know
about you but I will be thrilled to
warmly relieve myself on their grave and
to fight back against the cesspool of
Filth and sadness that is mainstream
media that's why this show lotta with
Carter's going daily starting January
9th Gary Sinise is our first guest the
rest of the guest list to come we'll
have the live stream free here on
YouTube 8 p.m. Eastern all the live
streams going forward are still free on
Thursday right here on YouTube 8 p.m.
Eastern but the show is daily if you
join the Mudd Club uh if you're a
student it ends up being less than 585 a
month lotta with credit com
slash mug Club will have a 7-day free
trial starting Monday January 9th we're
incredibly grateful we appreciate your
support and we're at the point here
where we're building out the studio
we're pretty sustainable but we want to
grow and bring in more names maybe even
some people who you've seen and watched
and loved on YouTube who could use some
help
being undergirded to fight back against
the mainstream media right now we
already have Mark Levin Michelle Malkin
Mark Steyn myself so big names to come
so um about five dollars a month you get
this awesome cool mug and access to
lotto with Crowder daily we
of a contest going on we'll be giving
away 50 free mug club memberships just
send your tweet to @s Crowder or at not
gay Jerry with the hashtag Crowder dance
moves and what you need to do is send in
your best louder with Crowder dance
moves to one of our bumps so it playing
in the background you can be pogo it can
be strange animals send in your best
dance moves and 50 people will get a
free annual mug club membership and this
beautiful hand-painted hand edged mug
and we'll have one lucky winner one
super winner who will get a free mug
club membership an entire merch package
a lock of not gay Jared's hair and a
private conference call with us even
though you don't really have to do that
and that winner will be picked on Monday
January 9th by our celebrity judge Gary
Sinise with the best most creative dance
moves thank you guys so much and I wish
I were talking to you under better
circumstances but we appreciate
everyone's who's everyone who I think I
had a stroke everyone who's helped us
fight back ladder with credit calm slash
mug Club see you Monday